How I got a training ship in the European Union.
Hello, my name is Olivia.
I did my training ship
at the council of the European Union.
I was also part of the Positive Action Program
for training with disabilities.
Cause I am hard of hearing and I use hearing aids.
They applied all lines through the platform they had
and I got in after 3 attempts.
So I can say that is a bit competitive.
Eligibility criteria is different
in its institution or agency of the European Union.
In general they just for university graduate.
Also you have to speak two languages
to official European languages fluently.
And one of them has to be English or French.
And then in my opinion
is very important
if you also have international experience
and work experience.
Because as I said,
is a very competitive process.
So with that you will get more points.
So this is it really.
If you have any questions,
you can type them in the comment
or you can reach me on Instagram.